how movies work has now changed staying
yeah we're now University of story
because of TV okay because we used to
just teach movies and we realize that
was limited so when we made the
transition we brought all of our genre
tools into showing how these things same
things work in television for instance
Breaking Bad is a thriller so all the
rules of thrillers that you might have
had and I don't know a mystery the LA
Confidential and by the way true
detective is a mystery thriller too so
all the rules of not showing the villain
of good news bad news of ticking clocks
all the genre tools that we used in
mystery thrillers three plots one plots
hidden behind the other all that stuff
applies to true detective all the
thriller rules of suspense and a making
an antihero sympathetic by making
everyone around him worse all of that
applies to Breaking Bad
so you just stretch the form and use the
tools so we could no longer say it's how
movies work so we thought well is this
just not how TV works either
it's how story works and by the way all
of these things we teach work in novels
too they work in books they work
anywhere there's a narrative form we
have a structural tool called the BMOC
which is beginning metal obstacle in
climax these are the four points in any
great story where the heroes asked to
change and they're in every great story
whether it's Star Wars or The Fault in
Our Stars or a fast and furious Tokyo
Drift
and these four points also work inside
every scene they're in every action
sequence to SPEA mosy so this rhythm of
story is present in all great stories so
we have a lot of novelists now and
they're they aren't even novelists who
want to necessarily translate their
story to television movies although a
lot of them are but this BMOC pattern
transforms their novels it transforms
their story we have a music video guy
who's coming to study with us because
this BMOC form works
in six minute music videos to so and so
do all the tools of structure and
suspense so it's all one thing I mean I
don't know it sounds very counterculture
II but it is it's all one thing it's
just one rhythm just like a pop song no
matter how cool or hipster has a chorus
a bridge a verse structure right
Kanye does and you know Raikou der does
they all do why because the human brain
is wired to have a certain set of beats
in any narrative form and that's what we
talk about this BMOC structure it works
always bad stories by the way don't have
this and that's part of why they're bad
most movies are bad most television is
bad and it's applying the tools properly
that makes part of what makes the story
is great it's simple but unless you're
conscious of it you won't do it if you
don't have good news bad news
raising stakes and and and ticking
clocks on every page of your story your
story's going to be boring but hardly
anyone teaches that it be in being
conscious of how those tools work is how
you start putting them on every page and
by the way these suspense tools work in
drama they work in romantic comedy they
work in every genre and they work in
television too so each page of a script
has to have those elements it's better
if it does yes if you go and look at a
Tarantino script or you go and look at a
Chris Nolan script or you go and look at
Allen's script you will see on every
page once you've been shown it that
every page has ticking clocks every page
has good news bad news every page has
raising stakes a lot of them have other
suspense tools too but writers are often
unaware of this consciously they don't
build this into their stories when they
write them so just being aware that
this is how and they're cheap Trick's by
the way it's good news I'm giving you 20
bucks bad news I'm slapping you ticking
clocks is just a bomb a bomb ticking
down it's a gun pointed at someone these
are not sophisticated tricks they're
simple but the greatest artists use them
in all of their best work you've never
seen a Tarantino script that didn't have
three or four pointed guns in nearly
every scene it's cheap and it works like
a charm it entertains and that's why we
also see these in television Breaking
Bad is nothing but a series of
excruciating suspense devices so
excruciating I couldn't even get ceci to
watch it and when you sit down to watch
Breaking Bad you often have to stop
because it's so repellent Leigh
attention making but that's what makes
it great
you